Tom Holland is one of the biggest young stars
in Hollywood today.
The 25-year-old actor was catapulted into
international stardom when he first suited
up as Spider-Man in 2016's Captain America:
Civil War.
Joining the Marvel Cinematic Universe is a
sure-fire way to join the Hollywood A-list,
and Holland was no exception.
"Alright, kid.
You're an Avenger now."
Since becoming an Avenger, the British actor
has had the chance to show off his acting
chops in various non-superhero films, including
the gritty war drama Cherry.
This 2021 flick proved to be Holland's biggest
departure from the wholesomeness of the MCU.
It follows a young former soldier who struggles
with PTSD after returning home from fighting
in Iraq.
Playing such a troubled and nuanced character
was quite the challenge for Holland, too,
who has since revealed just how much of a
toll the film took on his health.
In an interview with British GQ, Tom Holland
revealed the health difficulties he faced
filming Cherry.
Production began with the scenes depicting
Holland's character in the throes of addiction,
and his appearance had to reflect that.
Revealing that his trainer told him to "eat
only 500 calories a day and run ten miles,"
Holland remembered:
"I lost around 27lbs by running in a bin bag
every day."
While this would be a difficult turn for any
actor, it was made worse by the need to bulk
back up again for his scenes as an army medic.
Holland shared:
"It was brutal…
I got very sick, actually.
And it's changed my relationship with food
completely."
The experience was so grueling that Holland
has sworn off doing anything similar in the
future.
In the same interview with GQ, he said:
"I think I would find it very difficult to
find a role that would warrant that sort of
abuse on my body again."
Holland elaborated:
"This role took me to some of the darkest
places I have ever been, emotionally, physically,
anythingly [...] I would never go back there
again, not for anyone.
I am pleased I did it, but that door is now
closed and locked."
Engaging in such an intense physical transformation
for a role is difficult for any actor.
While Holland may not be taking on such projects
again, many other actors have undergone brutal
transformations for the sake of their art.
Christian Bale, for example, might be the
star best-known for his jaw-dropping physical
transformations.
He shocked audiences in the 2004 thriller
The Machinist, playing an emaciated insomniac.
The actor lost 66 pounds for the role and
was fully committed to truly capturing his
character.
Shockingly, just six months after filming
wrapped on The Machinist, Bale had to bulk
up to play Bruce Wayne in the first of Christopher
Nolan's Batman movies, Batman Begins.
The actor quickly gained weight after his
Machinist role — so much so that Nolan asked
Bale to actually lose weight yet again.
Bale later told Train magazine:
"I gained too much weight in the run-up to
Batman Begins.
I wasn't the size that Christopher Nolan wanted,
so I had to cut down 20lb or so just before
shooting — I was a lot beefier at first."
And this was far from the last time Bale rapidly
changed his physique.
He went through a similarly rapid transformation
for 2010's The Fighter, playing a man addicted
to crack cocaine.
Though a pattern was emerging, Bale has shared
that he didn't actively seek out such physically
grueling roles.
He told MTV News:
"... I didn't take this job because I went,
'Oh, there's a physical transformation needed.'
I always go, 'Damn!
There's a physical transformation needed!'"
Tom Holland and Christian Bale are far from
the only actors who have undergone extreme
physical transformations for a role, of course,
with the likes of Matthew McConaughey, Charlize
Theron, and Joaquin Phoenix also known for
dramatically changing their appearances to
suit a character.
Of course, you've got to admire these stars
for their commitment to their craft, though
it's hard to envy them for the toll it takes
on their bodies — and nobody could blame
Holland for passing on the chance to do it
again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.